a Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance and now we know exactly what
Trump meant by make America great again
make it great for the racists the white
supremacists the neo-nazis make it great
for the anti-semites make it great for
those entrusted to enforce the law who
break the law and who persecute
Hispanics make it great for presidents
who tweet about building a wall to keep
out Mexicans while a city with 36%
Latino and 27% Mexican heritage
population and the nation's ninth
largest african-american population
while that city is drowning make it
great for the homophobic make it great
for those too stupid to understand who
transgendered people are make it great
for those who must hate others make
America great again which means make
America white again this month last
Friday in particular has been the most
destructive month has been the most
hateful month has been the most
anti-democratic month has been the most
horrifying month has been the most
prejudiced month has been the most
disgusting month has been the most
unforgivable month has been the most
unamerican month in the history of the
American presidency this is not about
who elected him nor the forces of foot
in the nation which enabled him nor our
history of reactionary regression after
the fits and starts of progress in our
society nor who advises him nor who
influences him or who can control him
nor who is responsible for him this is
about the hate and the spitefulness' and
the limitless evil inside one man one
despicable unforgiveable feral man this
is about Donald John Trump a man who is
filth in a month in one month
Trump has seen the people who publicly
shouted threats against the Jews and
carried the symbols of the era of
lynching of African
Americans and equated them to the people
who protested those vermin he has then
falsely walked back his true sentiments
and read what a conservative commentator
called a hostage tape of a formal
statement the next day he staged an
insane enraged news conference the next
week
he gave an insane enraged speech in
Phoenix reading his first statement to
the crowd of morons and degenerates
we have always contained in this country
but editing out the damning part of his
own statement in a bid to edit history
the next night with no irony no sense
that we could see the truth of the
Emperor's New Clothes
they made a call for quote unity the
polls showed that whatever he thought he
was doing the number of Americans who
believe Trump actually discouraged white
supremacists was 3 percent 3 and by last
Friday it had become clear as to what
the word unity means in the diseased
mind of this hateful sadist Trump it
means unity of agreement with him it
means unity in not criticizing him it
means unity of all of us who look like
him unity in the suppression of all of
us who do not look like him in a span of
little more than an hour on Friday he
banned for no reason other than
prejudice loyal and patriotic soldiers
from our military because they happen to
be transgendered and he reportedly
prepared to remove the safety net for
those who were brought here as children
without documentation and he pardoned
Joe Arpaio one of the leaders of that
subdivision of those morons and
degenerates we have always contained a
man who targeted hispanics and
persecuted them and humiliated them and
used the law to break the law again and
again and was told to stop by the courts
and refused and Trump pardoned him for
refusing in that moment Donald John
Trump violated again the oath the one
which he falsely swore the one in which
he lied
the one he merely read Because was part
of the act the part in which he promised
to protect the Constitution Donald John
Trump ignored our Constitution again as
he always does as he always will do
until the necessary actions are taken to
remove him and this crowd around him
this crowd of venomous enabling thugs
who permit this nightmare to continue
the issues of right and wrong of good
and evil become more inescapable with
each passing week
Trump's prejudice against the
transgendered is only one part of his
frenzied demagoguery the excuse of
excessive cost tools only the
feeble-minded and so much as the
military spends more on erectile
dysfunction drugs than it does on the
needs of the transgendered trump's
prejudice against Hispanics is only one
other part of his frenzied demagoguery
as the picture of the horrors in Houston
became clear on Sunday morning he
tweeted 10 times 6 times congratulating
the hurricane response by the government
by which he means the response by him
once about his margin of victory last
year in Missouri once actually pedaling
a book by Sheriff David Clarke the RPO
of Milwaukee once about NAFTA and once
about the evils of Mexico and his
psychotic obsession with a wall designed
to keep out people who look like those
who are drowning in Texas early in this
month he had redirected funds from flood
coverage to this obsession with building
his dammed wall he threatened to shut
down the government to build that damned
wall he threatened to end da CA to
punish Hispanics because every demagogue
has to have a flock of human sheep who
joined him in rapturously hating one
minority group Trump's prejudice against
Jews is only one more part of his
frenzied demagoguery last week Trump
retweeted an eclipsed meme created by a
man who three days earlier had tweeted
quote we have enough Jews where I live
just as Trump had tweeted a month ago a
restful
video created by someone who had made a
series of anti-jewish tweets just as
Trump had issued a statement a week into
his presidency about international
Holocaust Remembrance Day that never
mentioned the words Jews Jewish or
Judaism just as Trump tweeted a year ago
an image of Hillary Clinton atop a pile
of money and a Star of David and so many
people said oh he's not anti-semitic his
son-in-law is Jewish and then after
Charlottesville he defended the Nazis
wearing swastikas who shouted quote Jews
will not replace us and Trump's
prejudice against african-americans is
only another part of his frenzied
demagoguery
he said both sides were to blame the
domestic terrorists brandishing burning
torches and praising the Ku Klux Klan
and their victims but Republicans
Republicans we will ignore these
terrifying hatreds this manifold
malfeasance in response to Hurricane
Harvey this Pandora's box of trumps
unforgivable crimes just for the moment
and we will ask you only about the
pardon of Joe Arpaio just for the moment
Republicans your quote president unquote
pardoned a man convicted of violating
the orders of a federal court your quote
president unquote sided with the rule of
one man over the rule of law your quote
president unquote defended dictatorship
over democracy you Republicans are now
either for democracy or you are for
Donald Trump you cannot be for both you
will be asked your answer will be
demanded by the American public before
we decide if you will be permitted to
walk away from this monster you have
helped to foist upon this nation
Republicans do you believe in the United
States of America do you believe in the
Constitution do you believe in the rule
of law do you believe in the rights of
Jews do you believe in the rights of
Hispanics do you believe in the rights
of women do you believe in the rights of
African Americans do you believe in the
rights of LGBTQ do you believe in the
rights of Americans or do you believe in
Donald
on Trump this nation will no longer
tolerate Trump and the hatefulness and
the divisive miss and the venality and
the prejudice he represents and exploits
and breeds
he will be impeached and you Republicans
will either help us to impeach him or
you will go with him give us your answer